he's Jim Boeheim Syracuse head coach
with the big win going to the sweet 16
where they will match up against Duke
and of course I called that Syracuse run
have you on I know you called us what
you really I wasn't alone I just I
thought that you guys were more of an
NIT team but I said if you get into the
tournament that's a team that can do
some damage I think that was the exact
quote I had coach so well we should be
in the tournament because the term that
wants to take people that can win no you
were right with that comment wrong
saying we were not supposed to be in but
I thought we could get in because our
strength of schedule was good that's
what the term that looks at the
committee looks at that and we didn't
have that bad losses and we had 400 one
wins I'm not sure what quadrant one is
for I know we have four wins there we
won two world games in our league which
is tough to win against top team I was
just mentioning to the guys that your
your daughter Jamie won another state
championship that's pretty cool yeah
three three in a row they've won it's
great it was so much fun I was having
dinner thinking about getting ready for
Michigan State and watching the
livestream of it they played a great
game they they start two freshmen this
year with three seniors and it was fun
to watch that and get ready for Michigan
State at the same time it's great great
for our players to have this experience
it's so hard to win games in the NC
double-a tournament and you know we've
already won three games so it's it's
really been it's been a great run for
this group well and you had to win three
in five days I believe so that hit so
that makes it even harder can you give
your kids a rest instead of yeah we're
gonna take it easy for today and
tomorrow we didn't practice much during
the five six days last week we're
playing three guys 40 minutes and
splitting up the time where the other
four guys but three guys have to play 40
minutes every night as it's a lot
to ask for because we have to go so hard
on both ends we really can't take a
playoff because we know we're gonna be
in a close game so I'm really proud of
the guys how they played in this
situation it's you know it's tough I
mean we had Arizona States at one stage
this year was in the top five in the
country TCU was really good and Michigan
State a really good basketball team so
it was great it was great fun and now we
get a reward we get to have to play Duke
which is they're probably the best team
left of the tournament with Duke and
maybe
Villanova can link anything it's hard to
differentiate between those teams and
just as you say they're the best teams
they'll probably get beat or something
but that's just the way this tournament
is it's college basketball is great
there's a lot of good teams there's a
lot of good players and you're gonna
have a lot of good games talking to Jim
Boeheim Syracuse head coach joining us
Continental Tire Coach's Corner does
your family fill out a bracket
you know I we usually do but I don't
think anybody did fill one out this year
they usually have one in the family and
I don't think anybody filled one out
this year I know I didn't so I'm glad I
did you couldn't get it right no matter
what no matter what you think you know
it's almost impossible how far would you
have had your team going if you fill out
a bracket well you know you know what I
would say for the public consumption is
you know I pick us every game but in
reality I thought we would have a great
deal of trouble with TCU because of
their would make up of their team the
familiarity of their coach with how we
play and then I would have probably had
a hard time picking us against Michigan
State and in Detroit
honestly it but you know when you go
into a game it doesn't matter who you're
playing if we were playing the Warriors
we would think you know somehow we can
win this game that's what coaches do
that's what players do
and every once in a while you can win
those games I also watching Duke this
year couldn't help but notice that two
three zone and his coach paid did he
copy off your paper and sampling your
zone defense coach yeah you know he's
doing a great job with it unfortunately
I don't think you should be able to use
it against us I think he should be
restricted to playing just man-to-man
it's not fair but they've done a great
job they play you know a little bit like
us they have their own way of playing
things he's adjusted it like he would
always do he's a great coach but I'm
worried about their defense but I'm
really worried more about their offense
their offenses inside outside I think
they're the best offensive team in the
country Bagley's the best big guy in the
country by quite a bit and they've got
senior leadership with Grayson Allen
who's won a national championship so
it's a tremendous test for us but we're
glad to be taking the test you know at
this stage if I said that the game will
be in the 60s yeah well I think it will
be in the 60s but you know it was in the
60s at Duke and maybe they had 60 and we
had 44 you know it'll probably be a
fairly low scoring game if it goes the
way I think it will a battle of two zone
defenses both teams are going to have to
take time to get good shots you know we
have to overcome their inside play their
dominance on the boards and and it's
it's a great asset for mendes challenge
but like I said you know we're there
we're trying so we get to go to Omaha
we're happy if it was you against Coach
K in a shooting contest no conscious
easy
easy win for me easy way really he he he
was a defensive player it's a Notre Dame
army army yeah you know coach tonight
what he loves you know he actually
wasn't good sir
but he coached I didn't let him shoot
too much he made him pass to the other
guard they had another guard that was
really I think Oxley was July it was a
really good shooter but no I I think I
could still handle him in a shooting
contest if you shot it bad hips if you
shot a hundred free throws how many you
making right now you know I had honestly
a few years ago I was making 90 now I
don't think so I haven't shot at all in
the last few years I wouldn't make many
out of price I substitute gerry mcnamara
home in 95 95 or 96 every day right now
could you tell Calipari if in a shooting
contest he can beat Eric Musselman yeah
no can't be there too no way
can't be this is just a shooting contest
not one-on-one yeah yeah I can't you
could take Huggins right well I don't
know if he could even walk out there I'm
not sure I killed him all the pants fell
down like he had to hold him up he was
going out to object to a coldie a couple
of weeks ago and his pants nearly fell
down lost weight he's lost a few pounds
and I said well I don't know it just
doesn't appear that you've lost a few
and if if you have you've certainly
found them quickly and we put them
someplace else
yeah don't look too far they're right
behind you when you would be all in
favor of the high school kids going
right to the pros it's only three or
four guys a year everybody's making this
big deal it's three or four guys a year
they can go just think of Trey young for
example if he to come out last year he'd
have been 35 in the draft this year he
has a great year great college
experience and he's gonna be in the top
ten it's been a great experience for him
I mean Bagley yes he would have been
gone Aten
eight and would have been gone Michael
Porter those are three guys that jump
right to my mind but it doesn't hurt
them to go to college it does not hurt
them and everybody talks about paying
players you know there's 4500 college
basketball players and 4400 them are
just like I was not gonna make any money
playing basketball someday I mean I was
happy to get a scholarship and there's
4,400 guys in college right now that are
happy to have the scholarship and cost
of attendance and we've done some things
to help student athletes and we can do a
few more but it's a pretty good gig in
the top 50 guys are gonna make millions
of dollars anyway playing in the NBA so
it all works out it all works out
you know this Commission I think 10th
week college basketball and help college
basketball but we've got a great game
we've got a lot of great players and a
lot of balance in college basketball
which is I think great I think it's a
great thing for college basketball I was
communicating with your wife and yeah I
think too frequently no no I'm doing
everything it's all aboveboard
I okay yeah all aboveboard with your
wife but she did call you a genius oh my
gosh she's never called me that is that
close in fact my quote to her was one
day you know I know some people think
I'm smart when she was criticizing me
for the tenth time the same day Wow
but she says she does that because
nobody else does so I let it go I let it
go I'm gonna let it go is that her in
the background yes of course I'll be in
the final all be its final four so
hopefully I'll see you I'll be there I
hope I have people with me good luck
against Duke there coach thank you thank
you thank you that's Jimmy huh yeah head
coach's daughter Jamie won the state
championship third straight year yeah
of a new Jim Boeheim drop this is a
classic this is his initial response
when you mentioned Duke is using the 2-3
zone there's a little Larry David in Jim
Boeheim
like a little bit and I don't know if
it's because maybe you know bald and
glasses but there there's just something
about the team is pretty Continental
Tire Coach's Corner whether you're
student alumni are all-around fan
continental tire has a tire to get you
to the big game for more information but
they want to know your ode to basketball
that's the hashtag ode to basketball for
more information visit Continental Tire
comm for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]